you and hitler have the same birthday oh
my god you've really done your research
uh well i i often google um
famous people that have a birthday same
as hitler yeah and the the the the
person that shows up
you know is your face just really big
you and hitler together just pals next
to each other no it does not i'm no but
april 20th is an embarrassing birthday
for all my 420 friends out there it's
embarrassing you share a birthday with
hitler i think it's 420s also has a
humor and an uh a lightness to it right
it's embarrassing
especially life is embarrassing but if
you like weed and you're born on stoner
day
and
you believe in reincarnation
do you realize like when you start
connecting the dots there if there is
like a bardo where you get to choose
your next life
so you're like a shitty
generic np npc you're you're like of
course of course you would be born on
420.
it's computer games
yeah
but isn't it interesting that on that
same day
hitler is also born
i don't th there's a
there's attention to that
um and that hitler's an artist
so it's like
that hippie mindset could could go
anywhere oh yeah right like what yeah
you know and i i like i was just having
this conversation with a friend of mine
who's a wonderful skeptic
and
we were talking about this uh
which is
the thing where you start attributing
to the day you were born these kind of
significance and based on maybe people
who were born on that day maybe some
other things
and you know it's like think of how many
people by now in the course of human
history have been born on april 20th i
mean
how many someone could probably do the
math and come up with some number close
to it
now
this is how you know how rotten hitler
is like he's the one that like [ __ ] up
every other the birthday for everybody
else but
i think where i heard the year 420
is wim hof
episode because he's also 42 420 yeah so
he
hitler beats even william hoff
look in terms of owning the date i think
if anybody
is is like well obviously there's
nothing you can do do to like fix it
hitler [ __ ] up a lot of things he
[ __ ] up that mustache he [ __ ] up the
name hitler he [ __ ] up 420 and
obviously he caused a horrific holocaust
that by the way talk about these
reverberations through time that we're
still experienced i mean there's still
people walking around with [ __ ]
tattoos from that [ __ ] so
but you know wim hof
you know people like wim hof there's a
little they're like
whatever the opposite of hitler is you
know he too is creating ripples in the
lake that hopefully
uh respond to that of hitler yeah a very
cold [ __ ] lake and he's in in and
yeah so very cool
very very cold lake that he's happily
swimming around in
you